I'm gonna be a princess all my life I
wanted to be a princess don't look how
nice you are you gonna make me a
princess
I had all the brothers so I was always
playing with the boys alive I was a
tomboy I always believed options Tommy
I'm still waiting for my husband was my
prince so yeah I grew up during the war
but I was not a princess I was tough I
can still remember my brother Mikey
taking me to see Snow White in 1937
I saw frozen and I really got a kick out
of it I watched it with my grandkids you
wanna make me look Cinderella I like the
princess Cinderella the princess and run
princess Cinderella yeah yeah I'm
excited too I love a makeover and I love
doing the princes I control my
great-granddaughter she'll be thrilled
to see grandma as a princess we were
young once
what do we really know about the Snow
White
is she really cure and like Ivory soap
oh she a [ __ ] God knows what she's
doing with those looks going to the ball
of meeting the Prince that's the best
part you got happy he's happy why is he
happy she's getting him both dogs
problems with me when I came here when I
arrived here I did not know the language
I did not know anyone I went to sleep at
night
and I was crying before I went to sleep
it's very very this was the one you know
you go to another country after your
ears then you're eight years old then
when I memorize you I don't know we hit
it off but it took a long time till we
started to go out everybody no one know
why waited so hold on every other day we
saw each other or he called me it was
really by nine months we were married I
think it's harder for girls growing up
today they just grow up to fear more
pressure and then then they can get in
trouble right away and we're easy to
compromise in those days you have to
learn to get along fight but get back
together every time I see my great
granddaughter and her friends they're
always dressing up with costumes and
they idolize
like frozen and cinderelly you could see
it they love to be princesses it's a
different world we weren't that much
into it because I don't think we had the
movies and the Disney stuff and now day
oh my god is that me oh my goodness oh
my girl my eyes I look like I'm strong
when I look in the mirror yes you're
wonderful I feel like I'm great of being
the princess is so much fun the makeup
the wig was fun I always wanted to be a
blonde now I know what it looks like we
forget that we're old we're having a
good time yeah every girl is a princess
they don't have to be a dressed up keep
on dreaming of princesses and princes
because hey if you dream hard enough and
you wish hard enough they say your
wishes will come true yeah so don't
breathe cheaper and layer when I
bellissima pretty best sauce I love to
have more Disney stuff because the
fantasy I am a thin princess who could
we could take that away from me right
now
no one